Auch, wenn sich Deutschland als “Vorreiter
beim Klimaschutz” bezeichnet: Die deutsche
Klimapolitik funktioniert alles andere als
gut.
Die Klimaziele jedenfalls, die die Bundesregierung
eigentlich bis zum Jahr 2020 erreichen wollte,
sind in weiter Ferne.
Und seien wir mal ehrlich: DAS ist wirklich
mehr als peinlich!
Doch jetzt gibt es eine Studie und das Ergebnis
macht Hoffnung: Deutschland könnte es DOCH
noch schaffen, die Klimaziele zu erreichen!
Alles darüber jetzt in Clixoom Science & Fiction;
herzlich willkommen!
Der Plan war und ist eindeutig: Bis zum Jahr
2020 sollten die Treibhausgasemissionen im
Vergleich zu 1990 um 40 Prozent sinken.
Davon geschafft sind deutschlandweit erst
32 Prozent - so steht es im aktuellen Klimaschutzbericht
der Bundesregierung.
Unsere selbst gesetzten Klimaziele verfehlen
wir also um acht Prozentpunkte.
Im Sommer hatte die Bundesregierung dann auch
Gründe - oder sagen wir lieber Ausreden - benannt:
Zum eine habe das Bevölkerungswachstum unerwartet
deutlich zugenommen - das liege an den vielen
Schutzsuchenden, die aus anderen Ländern
geflohen sind und seit 2015 in Deutschland
leben und so auch mehr Energie verbraucht
wird.
Zum anderen habe es eine “unerwartet dynamische
Konjunkturentwicklung” gegeben- einen Wirtschaftsboom
quasi.
Unter anderem liege das wiederum an niedrigen
Preisen für Gas, Kohle und Öl.
Und das bedeute dann eben auch mehr Produktion,
Verkehr und am langen Ende auch mehr Schadstoffe.
Und so klingt das Versprechen aus dem Koalitionsvertrag
von CDU und SPD wie eine hohle Phrase: “Wir
bleiben Vorreiter beim Klimaschutz”.
Doch es scheint so, als würde kurzfristig
rein gar nicht passieren.
Dabei ist es bis 2020 nicht mehr lang - zwei
Jahre Zeit haben wir noch.
Doch jetzt plant die Politik offensichtlich
lieber langfristiger.
Im besten Fall nicht aufgehoben, aber auf
jeden Fall aufgeschoben.
Die Bundesregierung setzt in Sachen Klimaschutz
also nun auf ein Gesetz, das im nächsten
Jahr verabschiedet werden soll.
Damit soll der Klimaschutz dann zumindest
bis 2030 wieder in den Vordergrund gerückt
werden.
Doch jetzt gibt es eine aktuelle Studie, die
es ganz klar auf den Punkt bringt: WENN der
politische Wille dazu da wäre, könnte Deutschland
die Klimaziele sogar bis 2020 schaffen!
In Auftrag gegeben wurde sie von Greenpeace
- und zwar beim Fraunhofer-Institut für Energiewirtschaft
und Energiesystemtechnik in Kassel.
Und die Voraussetzungen für ein positives
Jahr 2020 in Sachen Klimaschutz sind nicht
einmal unrealistisch.
Das Forschungsteam ist in beiden entwickelten
Szenarien darauf bedacht, die Versorgungssicherheit
zu gewährleisten.
Zudem wird Rücksicht auf die Gegebenheiten
in den verschiedenen Regionen Deutschlands
genommen.
In der Studie heißt es beispielsweise: “Um
die Versorgungssicherheit zu gewährleisten
und den Menschen in den Kohle-Regionen im
Rheinland, in Mitteldeutschland und in der
Lausitz einige Jahre mehr für den strukturellen
Umbau zu verschaffen, wird in den hier vorgestellten
Szenarien ein Instrumentenmix aus Stilllegung
und Drosselung von Braunkohlekraftwerken sowie
dem Ausbau der erneuerbaren Energien zugrunde
gelegt”.
Laut der Untersuchung der Fraunhofer-Wissenschaftlerinnen
und Wissenschaftler müssten insgesamt 14
Kraftwerksblöcke in Südwest- und Nordost
Deutschland stillgelegt werden - und zwar
bis 2020.
Insgesamt wäre somit eine Abschaltung von
7,4 Gigawatt statt 6,1 Kohlekraftwerks-Leistung
notwendig.
Laut Greenpeace handelt es sich dabei immer
noch um weniger als ein Sechstel der Kohle-Kraftwerkskapazität.
Zudem müssten weitere Kraftwerksblöcke gedrosselt
werden.
Laut der Studie alle, die im Jahr 2020 mindestens
20 Jahre alt sind.
Als konkrete Zahl wird eine Begrenzung von
6000 Vollaststunden pro Jahr genannt - statt
derzeit 7000 Stunden.
So könnte die angepeilte 40-Prozent-CO2-Reduktion
also tatsächlich auch schon bis 2020 erreicht
werden.
Dennoch ist sich Studien-Autor Norman Gerhardt
sicher, dass es sich hierbei um eine “versorgungssichere
Lösung handelt.
Im Großen und Ganzen müssten also die ältesten
Braunkohleblöcke in Deutschland abgeschaltet
werden UND zudem Erneuerbare Energien wie
Solar- und Windkraft ausgebaut werden.
Ebenso, wie im Koalitionsvertrag vereinbart.
Doch klar wird auch: Bisher wurden keine nennenswerte
Schritte für eine konkrete Umsetzung angegangen.
Abgesehen von einem ambitionierten Zeitplan.
Und so legt das Fraunhofer-Forschungsteam
gleich zwei verschiedene Szenarien vor.
Falls die Regierung - wie im Koalitionsvertrag
versprochen - Wind- und Solarenergie gezielt
fördert - sei die Abschaltung von 14 Blöcken
notwendig.
Konkret bezieht sich die Studie auf die Ankündigung,
Erneuerbare Energien gezielt zu fördern.
Demnach sollte es in den Bereichen Wind- und
Solarenergien, in den Jahren 2019 und 2020
Sonderausschreibungen im Umfang von jeweils
vier Gigawatt geben.
Zudem war ein Beitrag im Bereich der Offshore-Windenenergie
angekündigt worden.
Doch die Ausschreibungen sind bislang nicht
am Start und das Wirtschaftsministerium offensichtlich
wieder von seinem Plan abgerückt.
Deshalb geht das zweite Szenario von verzögerten
Sonderausschreibungen aus - dafür müssten
dann zwei weitere Blöcke abgeschaltet werden.
Anike Peters von Greenpeace gibt der Bundesregierung
die alleinige Schuld für den derzeitigen
Stillstand in Sachen Klimaschutz: “Nicht
die technischen Möglichkeiten fehlen, sondern
allein der politische Wille.
(...) Die Bundesregierung sollte unseren Plan
daher prüfen - und zügig umsetzen”.
Ansonsten sei auch in Deutschland mit wirtschaftlichen
Schäden des Klimawandels zu rechnen.
Und nicht nur das.
Die fatalen Folgen einer Klimaerwärmung sind
uns alles klar: Der Meeresspiegel steigt an,
die Antarktis schmilzt wie bereits die Arktis,
es gibt immer mehr Dürren und auch hier bei
uns werden die Wetterphänomene immer extremer.
Wenn wir nichts ändern, wird die Temperatur
in der Antarktis bis im Jahr 2070 um krasse
drei Grad ansteigen.
Doch die aktuelle Studie macht mal wieder
deutlich: Wir alleine haben es in der Hand:
Wenn wir uns nämlich mal zusammenreißen
würden und sich vor allem die Politik den
Klimaschutz ernsthaft auf die Fahne schreiben
würde, sieht das Szenario für die Zukunft
schon viel rosiger aus.
So und deshalb gibt es bei uns am kommenden
Dienstag um 18 Uhr den Klimastream, einen
Livestream zum Klimawandel und dazu, was wir
konkret dazu tun können!
Und das ist nämlich eine Menge!
Bereits vorher um 18:30 Uhr gibt es einen
Stream nur für Mitglieder und Patreons.
Da besprechen wir unter anderem die Themen
für den Klimastream!
Wenn ihr da schon dabei sein wollt, dann werdet
Mitglied auf dem Kanal!
Außerdem habt ihr ein paar sensationelle
eigene Emojis für den Livestream.
Mit euch Mitgliedern machen wir Clixoom außerdem
werbefrei!
Keine Prerolls mehr.
Immer wenn wir entsprechend viele Kanalmitglieder
gewonnen haben, schalten wir die Werbung vor
jeweils einem Video im Monat ab, bis es vor
keinem Video mehr Werbung gibt.
Werdet also Mitglied hier unter dem Video
und bekommt noch exklusive Extravideos und
noch ein paar weitere Privilegien!
Einfach hier unter dem Video auf Mitglied
werden klicken.
Tausend Dank an all diejenigen, die schon
dabei sind!!
Wenn ihr immer garantiert über aktuelle Videos
informiert werden wollt, dann added mich übrigens
bei WhatsApp.
Dann umgeht ihr die bei einigen etwas unzuverlässige
Abobox hier auf YouTube und ihr verpasst kein
Video.
Einfach hier draufklicken.
Hier geht es weiter mit (dafür drauf auch
klicken) „Klimawandel bestätigt!
Skeptiker endgültig widerlegt!“
Bis dann, bleibt dran!